what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard
and this is the channel where we talk
about all things data
data science statistics and programming
so subscribe for all kinds of content
just like this if you haven't already
and hit the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so this is going to be a very special
edition in my r tutorial series
we're going to kick off a new series in
here all about the carrot
package now for those of you totally
unfamiliar with what that
is carrot stands for classification
and regression ensemble training this
package was developed by
our studio and former pfizer data
scientist
max kuhn and the idea is the problem
used to be
you had all these disparate packages for
you'd have one
for pre-processing one for each
method that you want to use one for
summarizing the results it was just too
disconnected and all over the place and
the idea with carrot is
it's a one-stop shop for all of your
machine learning needs
now the reason i'm making a whole series
out of this rather than just one
tutorial
is because this package is absolutely
massive
there's way too much that i could
possibly cover in one simple tutorial
but
throughout the series we're going to
cover generally prepping your data set
up for machine learning purposes
visualizing the feature distribution by
class because we're
a tackling classification rather than
regression here
pre-processing the data set i'm going to
show you how to remove
low information features algorithmically
if you choose to do that
of visualizing feature importance the
various definitions of metrics of
performance
so things like sensitivity specificity
and positive predictive value
things that generally tell us how well
our classifier is doing
hyperparameter tuning using non-standard
sampling methods like
down or up sampling to correct for class
imbalance issues
altering our boundaries for classifier
thresholds
and then lastly training and resampling
multiple models
so before we get started here just a few
uh links
to point out here on just general places
where this tutorial series draws some
influence
number one the github documentation from
max kuhn
is absolutely phenomenal it's a very
comprehensive
uh documentation so highly recommend
getting
getting yourself acquainted with that
i'm going to provide a link here to this
absolutely wonderful tutorial from uh
author selva prabhakaran
so i got a lot of the idea for the
structure for this tutorial actually
from this one
um the first time i ever went through
this tutorial must have been a couple
years now but
i learned a lot from it um now i'm
working with a totally different sort of
problem here as well as just
adding a few different things in and
outside of the carrot package
uh but a lot of the influence and the
overall structure i got the idea from
this tutorial so
huge amount of credit goes out to uh
goes out to this tutorial
definitely recommend checking that out
and then lastly there's a tutorial i'm
going to provide here also on
just how you deal with some of these
class imbalance type of problems
so just a few more things before we get
started number one smash the like button
for the youtube algorithm
i'll have a link in the description to
my patreon account if you guys would be
willing to support me over there that
would be awesome
and then the script will be provided on
my github repo also in the description
of the video
so for this tutorial series we're going
to make use of the german credits data
set
now i really like this data set for a
tutorial basis
because it really illustrates some of
the real life problems that you're going
to run into whenever you deal with
machine learning problems
so we have one response variable here
it's a categorical variable class with
two values
good or bad referring to whether the
subject in question is a good
or a bad credit risk and it's a little
bit imbalanced
in the sense that good is going to show
up 70 percent of the time
and bad is going to show up 30 of the
time
and so actually in the real world that's
not necessarily that bad
like i personally am used to dealing
with 90 to 10 imbalances or even 95 to
5.
so when i see 70 to 30 i'm honestly a
little bit relieved by that
but regardless we're going to see some
of the challenges that that can cause
throughout this tutorial
now i this this data set has a lot of
variables to it and i'm not even going
to bring every single one of them
in but most of these variables are
categorical
so i'm going to bring them in and now
this isn't actually a feature of this
data set
but i'm going to do it here uh i'm
actually
for three percent of the age variable
and for 70 and for no excuse me seven
percent of the employment duration
variable
i'm just going to make these missing
missing data is a fact of life that you
are going to have to deal with
with real world machine learning
problems and i want to show you later
here how we're going to deal with
missing data
so all i'm going to do is randomly
sample through some of the rows for the
age variable
some of the rows for the employment
duration variable
and then i'm just going to make those
values uh into n a's
so just just just simulate some missing
data here
and just as a last step here uh we're
actually going to turn everything back
to numerics at the very end
but some of these variables i'm just
going to make into factors
so it's always a good step in any
machine learning problem just to get a
summary of your data set
get a feel for what we're working with
here and what we're going to see here is
for one thing this class variable here
again this is the 70 to 30 percent
uh response variable i was talking about
and
you want to look for some of these uh
variables that don't
have a ton of variation to them or have
some levels that occur very infrequently
like for instance this number of
existing credits a variable is a red
flag to me
now we're going to deal with some of
these problems algorithmically but
it's always a good idea up front just
explore your data set a little bit and
get an idea of what you're working with
now one of the weird things to point out
about this data set here
is that these factor variables are not
all coded in the same way
so take for instance the variables
telephone and foreign worker
now these were just coded as zeros and
ones telephone it's either zero or one
likewise for foreign worker but then we
have these variables
housing.rent housing.own and housing dot
for free so rent
own and for free are obviously different
values of one variable
that's housing and you can verify this
yourself
like if you look at all the rows either
housing rent housing owned or housing
for free
are going to be a one but
these are just different ways of
encoding these factor variables
and so it helps to have these things
in a consistent format and we're going
to do that later
but first just in the spirit of
continuing with our exploration of the
data set here
uh we're going to make use of this
wonderful feature plot
a function so for the feature plot we
need to pass in something to x
something to y and then optionally
something for plot here
now if you look at the documentation
here for the x we need a data frame
for why we need our response variable
and for plot you can select for
classification purposes
box or strip or density pairs or ellipse
let's see a couple different examples
here so starting with box plots
we can just see what the distribution of
employment duration looks like for the
bad and for the good
uh credit uh classes maybe a tiny little
bit of difference there
for age it's not as clear
alternatively we can do a density plot
instead
now i'm going to do this for the same
two types of variables
uh you can see the different density
plots
here now again maybe a little bit of
difference for employment duration
uh sometimes for different types of
visualizations you can see
things for one that you can't in the
other
but now actually let's take a look for
uh the property variable
which again this is coded in well really
four different columns here
and we see actually for this unknown uh
level here that's where the two classes
look probably the most different whereas
for the
for the others not really so much now
another
super helpful function from the carrot
package is this near
zero var function obviously that stands
for near zero variance
and as always the help documentation is
your friend
it breaks down exactly how the function
works
what we're going to do is we're going to
return the indexes of predictors that
either have one single unique value that
is they literally have zero variance
or predictors that have two
characteristics
namely they have very few unique values
relative to the number of samples
and the ratio of the frequency of the
most common value
to the frequency of the second most
common value
is large so there's going to be two key
arguments that we want to pass here
that's frequency cut and unique cut
frequency cut is the cut off for the
ratio of the most common value to the
second most common value
and unique cut is the cutoff for the
percentage of distinct values
out of the number of total samples that
is rows or observations
now this is not a perfect function and
you're going to see why
here the default of
uh arguments here our frequency cut are
95
over 5 and unique cut is 10.
now i took a more extreme case here and
it returned
more uh variables here but there are
definitely some limitations here
now in the more extreme case there are
more variables that get returned
but a number of these are actually
values
of the housing and property variables
remember from before
actually these were coded where a level
had its own column
so when your data set is set up like
that you're going to get some weird
results
as you see here and actually that
variable i pointed out before
number existing credits uh just to show
you that from
uh from before it's this variable here
where it's a little truncated in the
window here but
oh where the level four only appears six
times
that does not get returned by the near
zero variance function here
so again this function it's useful
but it has limitations so don't totally
rely on it
what i'm going to do here just for
handling my lack of variance in some
variables is
i'm going to take the recommendation
from the near zero variance function
uh in both times it was complaining
about the foreign worker variable for
lack of variance
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
use this uh factor collapse function
uh that's from the forecast package uh
to condense
levels two three and four into a level
two plus
okay now the next thing that we're going
to do in this machine learning pipeline
is we're going to partition the data
into a training set and into a test set
now to do this we're going to use this
wonderful create data partition
function from from carrich and now why
this is so helpful compared to just
using the sample function
is this function's going to allow us to
partition based on the proportion from
the response variable
meaning remember how we have that 70 30
split in our response variable
70 is the good class and 30 is the bad
class
well when we use this function this is
going to allow us to retain those
proportions
so in both the training and the test
sets we're still going to have that 70
30 split
now what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to want 70
of the data to be the training set and
30
to be the test set now you always need a
good
healthy amount of data in order to train
the model but you need enough
in order to provide uh some kind of
testing set
so that we know how well our classifier
performs
so a good rule of thumb here is about 30
percent maybe 33
for the testing set i've seen typically
anywhere from 20
to on the high end 40 percent
uh but 70 30 once again is a pretty good
split
so when we use the create data partition
function
it's going to return uh the row indices
so it's super easy just to uh subset
based on rows for our initial data set
to create the training set just stick a
minus right
at the beginning of our subset to create
the test set and then
we're good to go we've got two data sets
so just to do a final diagnostic here we
can run a summary for the training set
just to check for
uh red flags uh you can see right up
front that
the class variable did in fact retain
that 70 30 split
and now as far as the amount variable is
concerned here it's
important to point out that you do have
some outliers here but
we can handle that in our pre-processing
pipeline
i don't really uh see a whole lot of
other red flags here so we're ready to
go for other pre-processing steps
all right now the last thing that i'm
going to leave you with in this video
is this pre-process function and this is
where we really start to get into the
meat and potatoes of machine learning
because once again before we can even
think about training
uh models we need to make sure that our
data are processed and we have a really
good
solid format for both our training set
and for our test set
now there's multiple transformations
that we want to make to both of these
specifically we have missing values and
we need to impute those missing values
we don't have a consistent format for
our factor variables or for our dummy
variables
and we want to have a consistent format
so one hot encoding
or what you saw for the property and for
the housing variables where
you had a different column for each of
the le of the levels
and then lastly we want to normalize all
the variables
so the range from them goes between 0
and 1.
so we're going to do all of that just by
using this
pre-process function as well as also the
dummy vares
function which works in a very similar
way
so the key argument to the pre-process
function
is this method argument you'll see that
the default
is center and scale that is just
converting variables into z
scores but if you look at the argument
a description here you'll see possible
values for the method argument
include things like knn and pute or
bag impute or median impute
this is how we're going to impute
missing data
so these are just different algorithmic
approaches that we could take for
missing data imputation
uh i'm just going to use uh the bagging
approach
that is the bag impute method
and now what we're going to do is if we
just create this bag missing object by
running the preprocess function
it takes in the training set and our
method is bag impute
it's just going to return the model what
we need to do
in order to actually transform our data
is we use the predict function
the first argument is that model that we
just created in the last line
and then we have new data so the new
data is
i mean it's actually a little bit of a
misnomer because the new data
or the old data so pass in the training
set
store that in this new data the training
set here
and then bam our data are transformed
we're going to do something very very
similar in this next chunk
that is we're going to specify
a formula to this function called dummy
vares
because just like i said before we want
a consistent
format for our for our categorical
variables
what's known as one hot encoding so same
sort of thing as before
we create this dummy model object and
then we want to do
predict dummy model as the first
argument and then
new data which is really the old data is
a training set
now this is going to work a little bit
different
to how this last chunk did and that
what's going to get
outputted is a matrix and actually the
response variable gets dropped that's
why
i'm just going to call this training set
x because what's basically outputted is
a matrix of all of your predictors
i wrapped this functionality here inside
of the as data frame
function just to turn that matrix into a
data frame
so now i just have a data frame of all
of the predictors
i have to go back at the end and add
that response variable back in
but not before i normalize all the
predictors
so this range uh
value that i'm going to pass to the
method argument here
that's how we normalize what i mean by
normalize is
we're converting all the values to range
between zero and one
now in a situation where we have all
continuous variables i like to just
standardize
but we're going to normalize rather than
standardize rather
we're going to do a zero to one range
instead of a
z-score range here so we're going to go
through a very similar sort of procedure
here
just like we did up above and now in
this last chunk of code here
i'm going to add that class variable
back in
i'm going to make sure the name is
appropriate i'm going to call it class
right at the end here so once again i'm
binding
uh that class variable from the original
training set
uh to this training set x thing
which is actually the transformed set of
predictors
so response variable predictors all
together in one data frame
bam we're good to go so that's all for
today
in part two we're going to apply the
same procedures that we did to the
training set
to the test set we're also going to see
algorithmically
how you can identify features which
aren't really adding a whole lot from a
predictive standpoint
then we're gonna start training some
models so i'll see you all then
for now make sure you smash the like
button on the video
and i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data